rhettandlink along with their show good
mental morning were pioneers are
bringing talk show content on to YouTube
but over the past couple of years there
is no denying that at least
statistically they have been on a
downward trend taking a look at Goa
trends you can see it they peaked in
early 2015 and relative to their peak
they're only pulling in 19 percent of
that traffic now so here are a couple of
reasons that could explain this trend
starting off the content that they cover
on their show has drastically changed
over the years if you skim through the
earlier seasons though realized that
they mainly covered news content or
random life tips like how to stay awake
in class and eating content or
challenges were quite rare in season 4
only 7 videos out of the 79 videos in
that season had anything to do with food
or challenges however by season 14 79
videos 599 videos are about food or some
sort of challenge whether having their
moms take lie-detector tests or Wratten
link eat more gross stuff in fact
finding Riyaz on their original topics
was quite difficult they transition from
a talk show or podcast to a challenge or
try new things show now this is not
necessarily a bad thing and they must
have been consciously making this change
probably because these videos proved
more popular however is important to
keep things in moderation a challenge
video here or there could be refreshing
but when 80% of their content is
challenges it gets quite still pretty
quickly I mean how many times would you
want to see rhettandlink choke on
sketchy food and that brings me on to my
second point now only three videos
become more predictable repetitive but
they were also getting longer again
throughout season four their average
view duration was nine to 11 minutes but
by season 13 this increased to 25
minutes per day with 3 or 4 episodes per
day which simply felt choppy and was too
much this was clearly in an attempt to
play to YouTube's algorithm and garner a
greater average to a watch time for a
viewer however this isn't really their
fault and their partnership with YouTube
probably had a strong influence on this
before this increase in video length
good mythical morning episodes were
unique and exciting every day as it
covered different topics oftentimes
viewers wanted more
which got them going back everyday but
as a season passed by we saw more more
eating challenges that grew longer and
longer in length which actually made the
episodes on intriguing and I think that
may have actually decreased her average
watch time and another thing to keep in
mind is that there are seasons
themselves are getting longer as well
and this was all during time when less
content was actually doing better on
YouTube for instance take a look at the
channels that were really growing at
this time Graham Stefan was posting
three times a week
Matt dia Vella was only posting one time
for a week and then we have people who
took it even further like Mark Rober who
only post one time per month and there
are many channels that post even less
than that and are wildly successful all
of this brings me to my final and most
important point which is that they lost
a lot of creative power when they made
their deal with YouTube see a couple
years ago YouTube funded an expanded
version of the show as part of it at
supported originals initiative and this
is why they turned longer 20 plus minute
content this may have also influenced
her decision to focus more on chants as
opposed to the original content last a
year after his deal Co 71 decided to
bring back 12 to 15 minute video of
starting season 14 which is a clear sign
that they really didn't like the longer
TV style format either so to sum up
objectively a transition and content
longer style videos and Lawson some
creative power to YouTube hurt a good
mythical morning but that's just
objective rhett and Link were also
feeling emotionally drained by the show
on an ear biscuits podcast called why is
Rec going out as hair and beard Rhett
goes into depth about how therapy has
helped change his perspective and his
struggle of wake up every day to YouTube
comments that would determine his
self-worth on top of this rhett and Link
have admitted to having severe doubt in
the direction of good mythical morning
and when the show was going to end they
worried if they are made wrong choices
as the channel grew link said quote how
many things can we just keep eating and
I think that encompasses what the
audience was feeling as well good
mythical morning had simply grown out of
what a once was and evolved in something
that tried to play the favor of YouTube
which
not what the audience all rhettandlink
wanted this explains the changing
content the failed expanded format the
burnout rent link were feeling and
consequently the decline of good
mythical morning now don't get me wrong
here good mythical morning was an
amazing show and I really enjoyed
watching it but as a trying to show it
was simply a time to move on but that
doesn't mean the end of ran link though
they're still posting videos on good
mythical morning and they really seem to
be enjoying ear biscuits they're a
podcast show they are also apparently
vlogging on ran link every Saturday so
as they continue producing videos I
really do hope they do fantastic but
that is what happened to good mythical
morning if I miss any key points for why
the show slowly died then measure
comment that down below also if you guys
thought this video provided an unbiased
view on to decline then make sure to
LIKE the video and subscribe if I see
more videos just like this one but until
then I'm Mari I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]
you